what's happening you bad [__]
greetings from podcastville
it's monday i don't know what the [__]
the date is the 11th to 12 who the [__]
is
it's monday the joint is brought to you
by
blue chew listen forget the birds and
the bees
here's my lesson on love get blue chew
and combat all forms
of ed aka dead dick
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis
at a fraction of the cost bluetooth
brings you the first
chewable dick pill it tastes pretty good
too
this ain't no horny [__] you know
[__] spiderweed from the [__]
liquor store
from some guy that doesn't even have a
ged this is [__]
science blue chew is an online
prescription service
no visits to the doctor no awkward
conversations
no waiting online for the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped directly
it's way cheaper than a pharmacy so do
yourself a favor
they got a special going on for you
right now you know uncle joey always
shows up with something on a monday
try blue chew for free use promo code
joey at checkout
j-o-e-y at checkout just pay five
dollars for shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code joey
to receive your first month free and as
always
i want to thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the podcast
but i also want you guys to know that
this process is simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com you talk to
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you approve voila you'll
receive your prescription within days
and you'll be ready to sling dick women
will be walking out of your bachelor pad
limping you understand me
but it all starts with you you got to go
to bluechew.com
use promo code joey to get this party
started
go to bluechew.com use promo code joey
to get the party started let me ask you
guys a question
you guys want a ps5 they're hard to come
by but
my friends at cbd lion
have you connected you understand me
they
take care of you over that cbd line what
they're doing is they're running a
raffle it's either 500
or store credit or a ps5
you're gonna go with a ps5 so every ten
dollars
you spend you get a ticket you spend
fifty dollars you get five tickets
go to cbdline.com for details but before
you go there do me a favor
listen when it comes to cbd there's only
one line and that's cbdlion.com
the best but you know what it starts by
you going to cbd lion and reading
reading about cbd cbn cby
and all the benefits they could bring to
you whether it's with the cream whether
it's with the bath ball
whether it's the kinesiology tape the
chocolate the tinctures
cbd lion is always there for you do
yourself a favor
go to cbdline.com right now and read
also enter the contest no purchase
necessary you can enter the contest
while you're there to win the ps5 but
also
read read about cbn how it could benefit
you
and whatever you're working with
whatever is troubling you
cbd lion is there for you but it starts
by you going to cbdlion.com right now
and registering and
reading reading is fundamental reading
is what it's all about
before you can get the cbd line to help
you got to read to see how they can help
you
so go to cbdline.com right now preston
church or joey
and get 20 off your order and they're
having a tremendous sale
on 420 we'll talk about that some other
time but for right now
go to cbdlion.com right now
and now it's time to get this party
started
it's monday morning candles are lit
[__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday i don't know what the [__]
the date is
the 12th of [__] april it's a
beautiful
[__] day to be alive i hope you
guys are doing great welcome to the
joint
uh i had a great weekend i got no
[__] complaints
my daughter's softball game saturday i
was [__] psyched about that
uh had some other [__] going down but
we'll talk about that later in the week
um he's good you know feeling good
healthy
eating good sleeping good finally
figured out the [__] uh sleep thing
you know ever since
rogan put out that book about sleep
years ago rogan had a guest on
i've been trying to [__] uh figure
out how to
get my best sleep and i'm finally doing
it these days i feel good i'm healthy
but all that aside i want to talk to you
guys about something on mondays you know
we're in a business any business that
you're in whether you're
a plumber electrician a contractor
comedian an actor
you always go in there you always have a
first day you know it's always the first
day
you know for me for acting i had uh
basketball and bronx county a pilot that
you'll never see
that you'll never even heard of on cbs
or my throwaways you know those who are
two projects of mine that withdrawal
ways as an actor
but in any of those fields what i'm
trying to say to you is that
you always look at somebody else
for uh like to lead you you know like
i'm not saying that i want you to be a
follower or i'm a follower or anything
like that
but when you when you first go i mean i
still remember being a 19 year old kid
and going aspen electric
you know i had taken an eight week
course in a college and i didn't know
what i was doing
and they put you with another helper you
know and you kind of
you kind of look up to them they're kind
of like a mentor for a couple days
until you figure out who the cool person
is and there's always a mentor at a job
you always have a mentor when you when
you work at a restaurant
there's always somebody that you look at
and you can pay yourself to that person
and go when i get my [__] together i
want to be that person
you know all i am is a bunch of [__]
i just i don't know if it's imitating is
the word or
influence you know i've been influenced
by a lot of people
i have tons of influence because i've
left myself be open
a lot of people like no i'm gonna do it
my [__] way that's great okay
that's great i i appreciate that you
want to do your way and your way is the
best
but every once in a while you have to
let yourself get influenced by somebody
and go hmm
i'm gonna try it that way i am not by no
means an actor i am not
classically trained have i ever said i
was classically trained
you know i respect john bernthal for
going to russia i respect all that [__]
i really do
me i'm not classically trained i went
you know i was a criminal who
got on stage you know i couldn't even
become a musician because i wouldn't
trust myself enough
to pawn the [__] guitar or the pawn
the bass or the point thank god
you don't have to bring your own
microphone in comedy because i would
have pawned my microphone and i would
have been up there with [__]
you know those things the [__] bull
horns and [__] i would have i would have
[__] pawned my [__] so
when you get into comedy you don't need
anything you just need a [__] t-shirt
a pair of pants some sneakers and some
material to go on stage so it was pretty
easy for me
you know it was pretty easy then you get
to la and they tell you you gotta act
you know some people will say ah you
should act or whatever and
you know some people are smart they take
an acting class i take a class for
anything
if i don't know what i'm doing i'll take
a class
until i could get out you know what
happened with jiu jitsu like jiu jitsu
for example take jiu jitsu
do you know what happened to me with jiu
jitsu what how i burnt down on jiu jitsu
i had too many people coming at me
wanting to help me
and that's great you know they were they
were coming at me
from a great place in their heart but
they didn't understand that i was just a
[__] beginner so i got overwhelmed
with all this [__] high level when i
got into jiu jitsu
everybody wanted to teach me something
everybody had this type of [__] game
every
you know and at the end i just got so
[__] confused
i mean i'm thinking of going back now i
got no problems with that now
once my knee heals up but what i'm
saying is when you're
when you're first learning something you
focus on one person
you know so i moved to hollywood and
then now they tell you you gotta [__]
act
or they say to you do you want to be in
this picture or whatever and you as a
comic
you might as well say yes and take every
experience because it all helps at the
end of the day
it all goes into the same [__]
blender you mix it up and you whip it
back together again
i didn't know that then but now i know
that
but i always wanted to try acting i was
a fan of movies i was
always a big fan of movies big fan
actors so when they
gave me the call to act sure i went down
i had no
[__] idea what i was doing for
baseball and i had no idea what i was
doing for bronx county but then i got
into an acting class
and i had a semi idea i still remember
getting [__] called in
for a pile uh i picked up like four
episodes on a tv show
and when they would say stand on your
mark i didn't even know who my mark was
and i was already in l.a for [__]
three years so
i mean you know i'm being honest with
you guys so what you need to do is i
read one time
that gene hackman i took little pieces
of [__] that i read about
like when i got to l.a i know i was
going to do a lot of mob movies so i
read every [__] mob movie every
i read every mob book i could
so i could put backgrounds to the
characters i was playing
like today i got to put an audition on
tape for a movie
you know i don't know what the [__]
guy's name was but the other night when
i was working on the audition
i had to actually write the guy's name
out and give him a biography he
went to school in [__] north carolina
you know born to a cuban parents
whatever i always give that person a
life story
the moment before i know all that stuff
and then i learned about going on a set
how to act on a set how to [__] you
know
behave yourself on a set do you stay in
your trailer no you go on the set and
you watch
and you watch all the actors you see the
guys that been doing it for a while
you know whenever i get to a set i put
my [__] in my [__] trailer
and i [__] run to the i get to the
set and i watch them
shoot even if it's got nothing to do
with me i watch them shoot because i
want to see the style they're shooting
how fast they're shooting
if the director is a [__] dick if
he's patient
i'm looking for a lot of things you know
you're just looking this is what happens
after a few years
like i said i didn't want to act you
know uh
i didn't have the time that like there
was a acting program i
thought about going into but they wanted
you to go in there for a year and a half
and not take any roles
and then i ended up finding out they
were connected to scientology in one way
or another so i had
i had a rough i had a [__] when it
came to acting you know
all those [__] acting classes in l.a
you get something out of them but they
could only take you so far
it's that expression you could lead to a
horse to water but you can't leave them
to drink
they take you that far so now how do you
learn
by going on a set watching experienced
actors
and imitating them letting them
influence you
picking up little things you know when i
did spider-man 2 i picked up little
things from toby maguire when i did
longer shot i latched on to nick deturo
i knew he was on tv
for all those years and he would talk to
me i also
latched on to the quarterback from the
guards
you know buffalo bill boo i forget what
his last name was
we didn't end up being great great
friends but i would ask him different
acting questions why because
i don't have an ego and you have to
learn you have to ask these questions
nothing wrong with asking questions i
got 20 guys that ask me
comedy questions every day on any
platform
whether it's [__] uh twitter
patreon facebook they asked me little
simple questions about santa
if i could answer them i could answer
them but how do you learn the most if
you're trying to get into stand-up
by going to a stand-up club by working
out as a doorman for a few months
swallow your [__] pride what's the
big difference
and when you go on a set or you go on a
work site
or you want a construction site don't be
a [__] afraid to ask
i'd rather you do it right the first
time and learn how to do it right the
first time the [__] up
only a [__] [__] would look at
you and go you don't know what the [__]
you're doing
no come on let's go this is easy this
i told you a thousand times if you could
fog the bottom of a glass up
you could take a glass and fog it up you
could basically do [__] anything
it's just you you're just not wanting to
[__] do it you know
i mean i listen i'm not mclaren
mechanically inclined
i could change a flat oil forget about i
rather pay them 19
i don't know what the [__] i'm doing by
the time i save the 19
i'll have all of my eyeballs i'll flood
the [__] streets with oil squirrels
will be dying on the street
because the oil will go down the corner
so i like that [__] for the
professionals but my point is
when i go on a set i always look at
other people so whether you're in
construction whether you're in a plumber
a welder whatever you're always trying
to learn you go
you look at somebody who's doing it how
you like to be done and you emulate that
person
and imitate that person get influenced
by that person
i'm i'm not you know i'm not telling you
to steal that aura
but i'm just telling you to look at that
person maybe i'll try it that way
he's a winner for a reason he's in 20
movies and i'm in three movies
for a reason so let me go pay attention
to him he's the foreman
of this job for a [__] reason he's
the
you know a master electrician for a
reason let me go talk to this guy
never be ashamed to [__] ask for help
anyway with that being said my guest
today
is alessandro navolo let me explain
something to you about this guy
i loved him i worked with him on the
money saints in newark i had never met
with him before
i can't tell you how intimidating it is
even for a guy like me
to walk into the table read of the many
saints in newark
it's intimidating guys i could tell you
oh yeah i got this
no it's not you [__] your pants you know
you're walking into the unknown
if i walk into a room to do a meeting
and i see like bill burr and dave
chappelle
and rogan and [__] a bunch of guys in
there i'm gonna [__] my pants because
i'm with i'm hanging out with the best
of the [__] best
when i got on the soprano set you know i
didn't know a lot of these guys
but i know david chase don't [__] around
and i know the actors he had were worth
their [__] weight in gold
so again i went on the set and i watched
some people [__] do their thing
you know john bernthal had my back and
grudge match and grudge match
when i went to grudge match what do you
think i hang out with oh cool j when do
i find you know
when do i rap yeah yeah when do i find
time yeah that was me with sylvester
stallone on the boat no it wasn't
oh you hang out with de niro no i didn't
know nobody on that side i went down
there
sighed unseen going into the unknown not
knowing i knew the director
peter siegel and i [__] looked at
john bernthal for help if you look at
the
at that movie i played john bernthal's
like [__] nemesis
barbara de niro chases me out of there
but i looked at john bernthal now again
and many saints in newark
i had john burnt all there for support
but
i asked him questions as many questions
as i could
but i also looked at alessandro and
he took me under his wing and did a
great job so
from the many saints in newark and uh my
buddy here's a little [__] short chat
with alessandro nivolo from the many
saints of newark i hope you enjoy it
what's happening beautiful what's up my
man how are you buddy
uh better for seeing you holy [__] you
look beautiful
you look [__] handsome as [__] what's
going on
uh you know um just like
a year of not stepping foot outside
and uh you know not
seeing the the sun is obviously good for
the complexion
yeah you look great man and you're in
new york city
[__] here yeah i'm here in brooklyn
uh
at home my kid just got a new puppy
which uh yaps and pisses all over the
floor and uh my wife
is going on a spa retreat with her best
friend and and leaving me to
pick up the mess that's how it usually
[__] works out
man last time we spoke you were [__]
going through rome to get to australia
to get your son a [__] s.a.t test i'm
telling you i
never traveled more than i traveled
during uh covenant
unbelievable your wife was shooting the
show in the uk
i mean you were like [__] mad dog in
it and now you're
totally weird i mean i wasn't i wasn't
doing [__] except waiting for our movie
to
finish up and uh but she like
you know nobody profited more from covet
than
you know apart from jeff bezos than uh
than my wife
who like made her directorial debut
uh you know and they they said um
she was about she was like two weeks
away from starting shooting when
when uh you know on march 13th which was
like our first day of uh
the added filming that we were doing and
we got shut down and they were like
saying she wasn't going to get shut down
at all and
this was like panic time everybody was
freaking out and
i called up the producers and i was like
you know what's going on here my wife is
not flying back to england now
like nobody's getting on a plane and
they were like oh you know
it'll be a couple of weeks we'll shut
down and then it'll be fine you know
just carry on and uh so i was like you
got to be kidding me man like do you
know what's going on here you know it
was all this
stiff upper lip uh you know keep calm
and carry on
stuff and um so
sure enough they shut down but then
like three weeks later they were up and
running again they were like
the only other movies that were shooting
were like something in iceland and
something in in new zealand or whatever
and she was like the first thing
back and they uh threw us all back on a
plane like
in hazmat suits and whatnot and off we
went and and uh yeah then the
the italy trip you know my kid was
trying to take his damn sats and there
was no place to take him anywhere
in europe except in rome there was like
one school that was open there
and uh so we were like [__] it should we
just go down there and
do it there and we flew down together
and and uh he took his sats in some
suburban
italian high school with a bunch of
italian kids
in this uh like school with no air
conditioning in the middle of august
you were uh very nice to me on the set
like i looked at you at the table read
for the many saints
when i walked in i was as intimidated as
[__]
and your warm smile just [__] that
and the prosciutto little [__] breads
that they had
the prosciutto with the [__] bread on
it and stuff it was right behind me
i'll never forget at the table read i
was like oh my god
i'm [__] starving and i couldn't i
couldn't walk away from the table read
because those things were right [__]
behind me
next thing you know the we finished the
table read people are clapping
i turn around and go get like two of
them i come back and my script is gone i
go what the [__] this happened
they just clipped the script somebody
just came along and took the [__]
script and that was the end of it i
never saw the script again
you see i never understand that like
that's such a thing now i mean i think
it always has been
with david from what i know about the
soprano shoot that like i don't know i
heard rumors that
he had like actually shot some scenes
in certain episodes that didn't really
exist
just to like put people off the scent of
what was happening or whatever
uh you know i more and more i get
sent like movie offers
or you know meetings to have with
directors or whatever where they just
like say like you can't read it
and i i just don't i i don't get it like
i don't know why
people are so scared of their script
being read who cares
i mean do you understand it like who
cares like
you know the movie's gonna be what the
movie's gonna be there's gonna be good
or it'll suck but like
what somebody thinks of the script
doesn't really have any
impact on it at all as far as i can tell
but people are like just so
secretive about it now it's so guarded
about it you signed 100
ndas and the thing like explodes
in your face like you know an hour after
you
you uh get sent it and i mean it's like
cia stuff i don't i don't understand
what's going on
the first time i ran into it was really
with spider-man 2.
yeah with spider-man 2 they sent you
sheets
that were coated yeah and you had to
hand them in
at the [__] day of the shoot i mean
but that was raymie's process
i only had one line it didn't [__]
matter to me the line wasn't going to
change
but i started seeing that then that
people were very secretive
with scripts you know uh
i understand david's process how did you
even
come into this [__] world how did you
even come into this
david's world uh you know like
many saints the most uh old-fashioned
way i got sent the script by my
agents and they said do you want to
audition for this thing
and you know i guess like by the time i
was auditioning for it
there was a kind of like pared down
field of candidates
and um so like i don't think at that
point i was
you know one of a million it was like
you know they had a group of 10 guys
i don't know you know a bunch of guys
and um
i like i just did a video tape
at home and i sent it in and
um and then um
you know it was a really long process
after that
um a lot of waiting around to just sort
of
see what was going to happen and you
know eventually i heard
he wanted to meet me and um
david and alan taylor took me out to
lunch
and we had lunch one afternoon and
and we you know we got along great i
mean
this was like the first time that i'd
done a
uh you know where where i like had a job
opportunity that
you know where like having the name that
i have
that nobody can say and everything was
an asset
alessandro nibbler yeah i mean like
this thing i've spent my whole life
having to spell it 100 [__] times
having to repeat it having to say
there's an o at the end not an
a having to say there's two s's not a j
having to say there is not an x it's
like you know i mean people can't get it
and it's a weird
even like among italian
american names like it's not that common
like
i i don't know if it's like a more
northern name i mean my
my grandfather was from sardinia
and you know which is the island uh
under corsica
uh the other island not not sicily and
um
uh there's a lot you know there's a lot
of alessandro's there
and that is not like a northern place
it's a very
you know uh working-class
um part of the part of italy except for
this one little coast where all the
russian billionaires parked their yachts
but like where my grandfather's from is
in this little village in the mountains
in the middle of the island
and there's nothing there except like a
bunch of you know
shepherds and stone masons and
uh there's a lot of alessandro's there
but i guess like when the big
kind of you know wave of immigration
came
um there weren't that many uh you know
northern italians
and there weren't that many sardinians
they were mostly
southern italians maybe alessandro isn't
like a big
southern name but like you don't really
hear it that much and so
uh you know i i've just like it's just
not familiar to
to people who aren't italian and uh
so i you know it's confused people all
my life like in terms of like you know
for the a long time when i was starting
out as an actor people were like is he
you know foreign is he european
is he south american is he english where
the [__] is this guy from
why can't i say his name and
you know there came a point where i was
like god did i just really
blow it like not changing this thing and
like making it
some one syllable number you know what i
mean
and uh and then like
finally this thing came along and it was
like
the first time where i felt like
being called alessandro like
put me in like a secret society of of
like
people that david chase like
you know had some felt some you know
affinity to
just before i'd even met him
and uh it really mattered to him
that the person playing this part
like had italian providence and
uh you know knew you know
yeah came from whatever immigrant
parents and stuff
and uh and so we just immediately
had so much to talk about because of
that
and uh you know and then
all through the whole the whole shoot
like
it was just the first time that i really
got to like play a role that drew on my
like
family history and my like my personal
history you know i
most of my career up until now like that
has not been the way that i've been cast
so i had
i heard you're italian it's [__]
beautiful
like i grew up better when i went to
jersey i moved
i was surrounded with sicilians so i
understood it because i speak spanish
i could pick up a word or two yeah no
there's one i would talk about when you
were talking to the italian actress
yeah it was a little lost your italian
was book italian like
the italian you learn at school which i
took and failed
you know what i'm saying i took and
failed it all i remember is
uh i [__] even forget not bonjour
bonjourno senor professor
you know i didn't speak it as a kid like
my dad
um never see when my dad was growing up
his first language was italian but and
he learned english in school
but by the time like he was like in his
teens and
early 20s he was like trying so hard to
be
americanized you know and he was kind of
like
you know trying not to be this foreign
guy
and so when i was young like
he had really kind of like he never
spoke italian to me he he spoke time to
his parents when he didn't want
me to know what he was saying and it
wasn't until
i was a teenager and i started going to
visit
my extended family over in sardinia and
i have like
hundreds of cousins in this one town
where my grandfather's from
and none of them speak a word of english
not one word like not even hello like
nothing and uh so i started going there
every summer
and just paling around with them and
like literally this town is
is everybody there is my cousin to the
point where
like you'd be walking down the street
with your with
like my my i had this one cousin aaliyah
who was my my my age and he and i were
really close and we were
walking down the street one day and i
saw this really pretty girl and
and i you know nudged him whatever he
said
and he goes no kugina
[Music]
uh but so it was around that time
that i started to like actually teach
myself out of a book and uh i like
learned grammar just out of a book that
i bought and then
going and visit visiting my cousins and
stuff
and that's kind of like how i i learned
what i have you know it's not great like
it's all right now you went the [__]
yale
that's right what did you major in what
is your degree in
uh english which is like the soft
the soft degree you want to
and how did acting come in uh
well i i wanted to be an actor way
before then like
um from a really really
early age and uh
i think from like third grade or
something and i started going
uh and you know i didn't have anybody in
my family that were
actors or anything but i i asked my mom
to start sending me to like summer
drama schools and all that stuff and i
really
had the most old-fashioned career that
you could conceive of like you know
i went to like summer drama camps and
then i went to
i started interning as a teenager at
this uh
uh summer like theater festival
um in connecticut where they um
would like uh do readings of new plays
and a lot of the like big playwrights at
that time like john guyer
and john patrick shanley and august
wilson and people
all like workshop their plays there over
the summers and they would get like
amazing actors like in years before i
was there like meryl streep would be
there and
sam jackson and you know a ton of like
people who went on to become big stars
and stuff but at the time i was just
like literally like doing odd jobs
and uh you know getting drunk and
and uh you know getting up to no good
and
just like building sets and make you
know cutting splicing sound tape and
that kind of [__]
and then um i did that for like five
straight summers and the last summer i
was there
they like invited me to be part of the
company and do a couple of like
young roles and and uh plays that they
were developing there
and that was like my first professional
start and then i went on to like do like
regional theater stuff around the
country and
i did plays in seattle and philly
and you know just all over the all over
the
the u.s for a the last two years that i
was in college
and then when i finally got out i was
in uh new york for uh
in the first year i was in new york i
got cast on broadway opposite helen
mirren
in this um uh turganev play
and uh know it was her and and f murray
abraham
and that was like you know i was off and
running then just a year out of out of
college but i had like
it had been years of like even at that
point already it had been years of
like doing you know stuff in in the
regional theater little theaters all the
time
so you learn from the [__] inside out
i mean
well i mean i you know i i guess it was
like
it was it was the co my career is like
by that time a lot you know most people
were just like most people who were
going to be in movies were just
like you know in movies like they
they weren't sort of [__] around in
like
[__] regional theater and and bum
[__] wherever they were like
you know heading straight to hollywood
to make it happen and
that wasn't really my ambition at the
time
i was i really kind of like
wanted to be a stage actor and
uh it wasn't until when i was doing that
play on broadway there were all these
other young guys
uh jew law billy crudup
damian lewis rufus like there was a
whole bunch of guys who were all
doing broadway plays at the same year
that i was and we were all like
going out all night and you know
getting up to you know mischief until
the sun came up every day and then
sleeping all day and then going
and doing these plays and then we meet
up after right after the play and
started all over again and
and we did that for like six months and
then one by one
each one of them like started going off
to do these movies and i was sort of
like wait
what the [__] is going on like
everybody's going off to
make these movies and i was abandoned
and i suddenly
felt jealous and like i've been kind of
left behind
and that maybe like my ambitions were
in the wrong place and that was when i
kind of sort of
like woke up a little bit and was like i
think i think maybe
there's like a whole other world for me
that i hadn't ever really conceived of
for myself and
and that was when i uh headed out to do
face-off that was my first
uh my first movie travolta face-off
yeah yeah wow it's crazy how
you did listen people go to hollywood
they join a [__] acting class you
know
they expect the best they get a couple
short films they go to festivals
whatever and then they fizzle out
you know i admire the guys like you that
you did it you did what a comedian does
you did an open mic for [__] five
years
you know it's like before this is my
30th year doing comedy
but what i don't tell people is the
first four months of me doing comedy i
clean bathrooms
i [__] lit the stage i swept the
front i [__] did the sound
i was the doorman i had a [__] you
know
i learned it from the inside out i
looked at
questions i kept my mouth shut and i
asked questions so before i got
on stage yeah i was a [__] i'm not
gonna lie to you it took me [__] you
know
five months of you know this internal
conflict
and then you start to do these
things and then you know i was telling
my wife the other day i saw this whole
[__] country
i performed in every state except
[__]
hawaii like i've been i i scored coke in
south dakota
that's my biggest accomplishment that
should be on my resume
that i made eye contact with a mexican
waiter in [__] south dakota
snake pits south dakota and i got coke
in [__] south dakota i mean i mean
i've been everywhere you know like
through comedy this is what you need to
do interesting it really
is like you know
comedy is now the kind of closest thing
to
you know that kind of like starting your
career through theater through live
performance because
most people in movies now they like
because television is so pervasive
everywhere there's so many like
little television jobs that you can
start with that like most people just
start
that way they just start on camera but
like the live
thing is like it really you know
it's like a dunk and an ice bath you
know
live theater to me has to be
it's one of my biggest fears and i'm not
scared of [__] when it comes to
i did general hospital you know what i'm
saying that's fast
you even do a soap opera they don't [__]
around they don't even talk to you
they don't even look at you they just
tell you to sit in your [__] room
until your number comes up
you go out there you think you never did
a soap opera yet have you ever done it
i did do one i think uh i can't remember
it might have been guiding
like it was in new york in like it must
have been like
i'm thinking uh i think it was like that
was the first
like the only the first thing time i've
ever been on camera was one day on that
i
i called out my agent i was like i can't
pay my rent like what am i going to do
and he was like i
i might have something for you the next
thing i
knew i was like waiting for my number to
come up in my dressing room oh my god
they didn't even talk to me like i got
there you gave them the
license they told you to go to room 22
your wardrobe was there nobody there
wasn't an a.d
nothing nothing i [__] sat there in
my room
all of a sudden they go scene 22 come
out they do
one rehearsal and you go
and let's say you [__] up your line
they're like you're not going to start
again you're going to start
right from where that line is and boom
boom a bell goes off and you move on
you're out it's that nine to five
i wish i would have known that i would
have gotten a [__] soap opera job
it's kind of amazing like it's got its
whole it's a whole world
unto itself it's like the porn industry
like there are these like stars
in the in the uh you know in that world
and they rule that those sets you know i
mean they've been there for like 20
[__] years
doing those shows you know and it's like
their living room or whatever
and they just like own the place and uh
you know like some of them might you
might never have heard of
one of the most i think one of the most
exciting things i was ex
one of the things i was excited about
the most about moving back to new york
and i'm still very excited about this i
got vaccinated and i'm excited because
i want to go start seeing small time
plays
yeah you know off-broadway plays that's
where you see the nuts and bolts of
acting
that i got to see a few times in la but
l.a has no [__] theater
they really don't they they can't resist
because they really want to be movie
stars
yeah like once this clears up a little
bit my friend's sister
works as a you know she does works for a
theater production
and one month you [__] wash toilets
one month you run the lights one month
you're the plumber in the play
one month you sell tickets and it's a
good thing because it'll teach me from
the inside
i don't care that i'm 58 i'm not looking
to be a movie star
but it's something just to do you know
two nights a week to replace comedy just
to
yeah just to [__] i would love to do
something like that well i think it's
all gonna come roaring back that's
that's my guess i think it's all going
to come back soon because
people are just dying to uh you know
have communal experiences and
um but you're right it's those little
theaters where um
some you know in new york at least when
you see a lot of a lot of the good stuff
because the thing about broadway now is
it's just like
it's gone the same way that the the film
industry is gone where like
everything is just these huge spectacles
and um
so like you know most of the plays are
like big musicals and things
there and so the the the you know
stuff that has uh you know more
more ambition for for just like straight
plays or
it's all off broadway so yeah i want to
see bare bones [__]
yeah i want to see the background [__]
yeah well we'll we'll go together let's
do it
i mean i um i try to do a play
every few years uh but like the last
one i just got like i found myself at
times just like sitting in my
dressing room with my hands just going
like that before the show every night
it's like it really like it's hard on
the heart
you know like it's
it really is stressful
i've shot pilots in front of live
audiences
and i've done okay you know it's
something to you look at it you absorb
it you go wow it's a complete different
[__] thing
i think the thing that blew my mind the
most was about two years ago
there was this hot hollywood show on
monday nights
a comic an actor anybody could go up on
stage with a band
you did 15 minutes of material 10
minutes of material
and then you had to sing a song
alessandro i went up there no problem
with the comedy no problem
would you sing uh the one by rage
against machine
[__] you i won't do what you tell me you
know whatever
so it's so funny because what you're
supposed to do is say thank you
turn around and then they start the
music
and you face the audience and you start
singing you know
yeah let me tell you something i turned
around the band started playing when i
looked back at the audience
singing and doing comedy is two
different [__] worlds do you
understand me two different [__]
worlds
i turned around and i could feel the
turd like a half
inch just came out of my ass i was like
what did i get myself
into and now i gotta sing this [__]
song
it was it was just so it's a different
energy
you know and i thought about like when i
left there that night i was like that
was [__] mind-boggling i got anxiety
and
and i thought about live theater i
thought about the honeymooners
you know ricky ricardo those
[__] used to do those shows
in front of live audiences i can't even
[__]
it's too much well yeah it's like
there's too much guys like uprights
business we're getting stuff to do those
yes hip-hop shows with live audiences
every night i mean
i think it's like i'm sure you feel this
would stand up like
it's like a muscle so you know once once
you get into the rhythm
of doing it night after night uh you
know you
the whole thing just becomes like almost
like muscle memory
and you know you relax into it or
whatever but uh
i still found it like really sphincter
quenching
you know like um and i was sitting you
know i was doing this play with bradley
cooper
the elephant man and uh
you know we had done this play a lot
like
we did it up at williamstown for a
summer and then
they moved it to broadway two years
later
and that was and then then we moved it
to london
so like all in we did this play for like
a year
and i was still just like [__]
myself
uh you know before each show i'd go and
have like diarrhea
before i'd go on every night and
he would come in we shared a dressing
room
and he would come in just like i mean
you know eight shows a week like
you know and if you have to do something
emotional in the thing or whatever
you're just like
you come into the [__] theater and
like you're just staring at yourself in
your dressing room mirror and you're
just like oh my god i can't believe i
gotta do this again
why am i doing this you know and he
would come in
like [__] tigger you know
uh just like so jacked and
and ready to go and he'd be like
bro bro do you realize how [__]
lucky we are do you realize how [__]
lucky we are to get out there and do
this
and i'm like
you know and uh and then like we get out
there
and you know he was really kind of
amazing because
a guy has got so much energy and
every night like he would sort of
you know we'd make it a little bit
different every night and he would like
drag me you know onto the stage and we
would like
you know make it alive again or whatever
and then like
you bow and you have like a moment of
just like
the greatest like feeling of relief that
you could imagine
like you just had the biggest dump of
your life
and then like about an hour later
it starts in again like i i got to do
this again
so you would do two shows a night
tomorrow you know would you do two a
night
two in a day we do like uh uh on
wednesdays and saturdays you do like
two uh and then right then you could
like have a nap
and then you'd go and do it again uh at
seven or eight or whatever
you know when i got into stand-up see
it's changed now stand-up is now a
thursday friday saturday thing
yeah but when i got into stand-up it was
tuesday through sunday
alessandro by friday night you were
ready to put a gun in your mouth
because you had already did tuesday
wednesday thursday
you had already done five shows you had
three more on saturday
and one more on sunday
the second show you're on stage and you
don't remember if you sang this joke
already
or you didn't you don't know if you this
is the first show or the second show
and forget the [__] third show like
somebody was telling me they're going to
florida there's a club that does three
shows mandatory i'm like
they'll never see my cuban ass because
those three show
nights [__] ended for me a long time
ago that's a nightmare you don't
remember what you said
so the third show you're up there just
floating going
i might as well improvise because i
don't know if i said this already
tonight and how i said this
it's such a [__] lesson when you
listen no matter when you don't want to
like right now i don't want to perform
because of covid and what's going on
like i've got my own personal reasons of
why
but when i was getting into comedy
it didn't [__] matter how i felt i
had to get up there
and you know you go through this [__]
you know when you're doing in the
beginning when you're doing comedy
you're basically just getting [__] on
every night people tell you you suck
you know people don't talk to you people
make no eye contact with you it's a
it's a constant thickening of the skin
you know it's constant
it's a [__] beating you know yeah so
you and back then like i had no choice
my goal was 30 sets a month
that's one spot a night that was my
minimum
do you know was like do you feel as you
get older like
that you still like that you still
profit from
you know just standing up and
like having like arrows thrown at you
like do you feel like you still
i don't know somehow benefit from that
or do you feel like
you know what like i just don't want to
like
put myself in the line of fire that way
in the same way as when i was younger
dude like how do you how do you look
good is life if you're not getting
arrows thrown at you
can you imagine just living life with no
it would be a [__] boring [__]
thing because i can't react
you know what i'm saying i like arrows
thrown at me it makes my [__] dick
hard
i love doing podcasts i like doing good
podcasts i like doing bad podcasts
i like doing them all to get a reaction
but you're doing
and that's what people don't understand
you're actually you're not
a potential energy your kinetic energy
whatever the [__] don't confuse me i'm
stupid
but you're actually doing it so i don't
give a [__] if you want to throw arrows
at me i got to keep doing what i'm doing
and the goal is to deflect those arrows
yeah you know for 15 years
you feel like your you know stand up
style
has changed a lot over the years like
have you uh
you know either like consciously or
unconsciously evolved as
as a stand-up abso-fucking-lutely
because when i started i started out as
a joke teller and when you're a joke
teller it's great
you you're funny people love you there's
a certain connection
but then i evolved into storytelling
kind of sort of and
reflecting from my life and putting on
stage and that's a deeper connection
letting people i i never wanted the
audience to think i was above them
i wanted to tell the audience guess what
i [__] in my pants the other day driving
on the jersey turnpike because i
couldn't make it to the bathroom
i'm just like you i have flaws just like
you
you know i i can't go to new york you
know why because i know i got to stop
and piss 18 times
especially when i go to the gym i drink
the protein drink before
the six the 92 ounces of water during
and then the little protein drink
afterward
i get in the car i gotta pee area
[__] [__] minutes i gotta pull
over at every [__] rest stop in new
jersey every [__] eight minutes
put my mask on piss and you can't piss
outside
a cop catches your next thing you know
you're not a lot of kid plays no more
because
you decided to take a piss at the side
of the park and you didn't know that
you didn't you i didn't even know that a
friend of mine got caught taking a piss
in the park
you got to register as a sex offender
you need that [__]
you need that [__] you know a 58 year
old guy so now
like there's somebody that you were was
like comedy style
changing at that time and you changed
with it or like was there
one person that you saw who was kind of
like
fighting this kind of elliptical way of
you know storytelling that was bringing
a joke
around and having a bigger payoff at the
end or whatever that like got you fired
up or
like what what was it that started you
uh
you know you know uh morphing into this
other type of comic
i had a dear friend that i loved with
all my heart he's a comedian
he's not doing comedy anymore but he was
very funny he was a very
one-liner type of guy and
he got a special one time like a spot on
a special with other comics
yeah and i wanted to support him so i
put the special on
and i was watching it but all of a
sudden i had to take a [__]
i had to go to the bathroom so bad and
i'm waiting to see this guy but i got a
[__]
i'm starting to get anxiety so sure
enough i get up to go to the bathroom
my girlfriend wasn't home at the time so
i left the bathroom door open so i could
listen to him on stage
and when you watch comedy and when you
listen to comedy
it's two different worlds there's people
that watch this podcast
on youtube and there's people that
listen to it on the drive home
it's two different [__] experiences
so when i heard
him doing those one-liners
i was like this is [__] horrible i
never told him that
we're still dear friends and he's
selling real estate and [__] florida
or whatever
your story about the guy who inspired
you
because i realized i was up there
chucking
no i wasn't connecting with you yeah so
i want to connect with you i want to let
you know that i put my pens on one leg
at a time just like you
that's the most important thing in my
game i want to know that you know what
i guess what i [__] my pants two weeks
ago guess what i fell off the bed guess
what i fell off my bike
you know i never wanted to talk down to
the audience or sound
swarming it also got like really
confessional
right so i got really like [__] tell
them a story
take them to take them to that place i
love when i make them cry
if you make them laugh you got to make
them cry so sometimes you got to make
them cry too
so these are all the lessons that you
just learned in the 30 [__] years
like you you've been doing it now for
how long
how long has this game been going on for
so i
i guess like my first real
professional gig would have been
1991 or something so
30 [__] years my friend
and that's why i fell in love with you i
would like
when i got on that set i had been you
know i've been in a ton of movies
but this for me was sacred when i got
the call
to be in the many saints in newark
everything had to change for me like i
knew
i had to change everything i prepared i
you know i did everything i could i flew
to new york i did the table read with
you guys
great time then we went back and we shot
the first day i was very intimidated
if you remember i was improvising a lot
i was [__] yeah what was our first day
was that
saturday's where where where what was it
um
i i think we were doing the back end of
uh
of a scene it was just you and me in a
room and you had to do something
we won't discuss it but uh
i remember that i was watching you
and i was like this is [__]
tremendous it's like watching
christopher walken
have you ever seen christopher walken do
a set
i uh played uh christopher
walken's son in a road picture
i'm going to show you a picture um and
we spent i'll tell you a little story
about him we spent
um i guess like two months
doing this movie about a father and son
um who like take this road trip together
and he uh here there's us
wow how long ago was that
that was like i want to say like eight
years ago or something
so we're like we're in um we're filming
in albuquerque
and uh you know we spent so much time in
this
[__] car together that like on our
days off like it didn't even occur to me
that i was gonna call the guy
up and say like hey you want to get a
drink or whatever because like we've
seen just too much of each other and
so i was just wandering around
albuquerque on my day off and i look
across the street and i see this guy
and it's him and he's in this like
floor-length black
trench coat and his hair is like
standing straight up and
he's wandering around like a zombie just
like looks so depressed and confused and
so we come in the next day to work and
i'm like hey man listen i
i i don't want you to think i'm like
following you around or anything but i
was in town yesterday and i saw you
walking around
and i gotta say like you know you didn't
look that happy like everything all
right how you doing
and he says um
albuquerque they're not my people
and uh and so i'm like uh yeah you know
i mean i can
see how there's a mismatch there and uh
so
then like uh about three weeks later we
end up
filming in atlantic city which was the
end of the shoot
and the minute we get to ac he's just
like
lights up like transforms he's bounding
around on the you know balls of his feet
he's recounting me all these stories
about being on the boardwalk as a kid
with his dad
and getting in fights and stuff and and
um
we're like doing this one scene driving
through town
and um the car it's like this was still
when we were using real film
and they had to change out the mag on
the
on the mount on the car and we
pull over the side of the road and
they're changing the mag and you know we
get out to stretch and we look across
the street and there's like
the longest line of zombie looking
people you have
ever seen like it looked like michael
jackson's thriller or something
and it became clear there was a
methadone clinic there and
and like everybody was there to get
there fixed that morning
and suddenly one guy looks up and looks
across the street and sees chris
and he's like hey
it's the king of new york and like
suddenly like
all these ghouls like turn and look at
us
and everybody starts freaking out and
they start coming across the street you
know towards us like you know
coming at us and they're coming at us
and they swarm around
all of us and it's like they're all like
just like
pawing at our clothes and stuff and they
come up and they're all around him and
touching him and stuff and grabbing at
his face
and everything and he's a really tall
guy and he's towering over them and he
looks at me
across the car and he says these are my
people
i never met him i met his wife yeah when
i read the sopranos the first time
yeah i was i was waiting for at 11
o'clock
with her like in 92 000 maybe
yeah uh her assistant see me at
caroline's
yeah and i'm outside in the street and
she comes up to me and she's like hey
i'm casting the show you might be good
for once you go upstairs and
leave your name and number i go jan i'm
you're 11 o'clock
so she's like come on walk in with me so
we walked in we got on the elevator
and i got to ask you a question is it
true that christopher walken is your
husband
and she goes yeah and i got to tell you
something else
his best movies at close range and she
[__] lit up she goes
you're right i always say that also wow
and that was it i went and i auditioned
i didn't get the role so what the [__]
you want from me you know
you try to butter them up your fingers
all
the sopranos what happened did she cast
all the episodes i think so georgine and
i had a partner who was also
a sweetheart in la she took care of me
she put me in something and then she
like tried to get me into like
a couple travolta movies the sequel to
get shorty
yeah because it was walking something
casting
yeah yeah georgine was in new york and
her partner was in la who was
great lady to me yeah so i got no
[__] complaints before you
before you get the [__] out of here i'm
taking enough of your time
before you got this movie were you a fan
of the show
oh yeah yeah you watched the show and
was like what the [__] is this
yeah i mean i i just felt the way that
uh
i think everybody felt which was that it
just especially when it started it just
felt so different than everything else
on tv and it still does like to me
like i think i feel like everything else
is kind of imitating it you know what i
mean um
the way that television evolved all
evolved uh to try and
kind of tell stories the way that that
did
um but imperioli was always like
you know in a way the guy i most admired
on the show
and uh so it was cool that i was going
to be
playing his dad and you [__] did a
great job
for me dawg this is how i felt i went in
there and that first day with you
we had a great time we're giggling about
something i knew you weren't like
you know an la actor i was like oh thank
god this guy's not you know
i had you and john to [__] guide me
through this thing
and you know i check with you i check in
with you from time to time and i check
in with john and it's because
you guys helped me through this i didn't
get david chase's style of shooting
to the second day and then i was off and
running
then i was off and running my first day
i was a little like
improvising and [__] and then somebody
came over and
yeah and somebody whispered a little
something in my ear and i was like i get
it
that's it and then i got the magic who
was david chase
yeah like then i i was like oh [__]
i get what this guy's trying to do and
you want me to tell you something
it helped my comedy because i remembered
lesson number one of comedy
let the joke settle and hit
i have a mistake all comedians do
because we get excited we gotta laugh so
we step on our own lines
david chase don't step on his [__]
lines
yeah he gives you a line and it goes and
it goes and it goes
and it resonates yeah and that's what i
learned from david chase
uh i've told i told a couple people this
and i don't need to blow smoke up his
ass you know i love him to death
to me i don't need to do another movie
i'm done
if i don't do another movie after this
regardless of what it does in the box
office
whatever whatever just me being from
jersey
being cuban yeah being from [__]
north bergen
and being able to be in a many saints in
newark it has been
such an honor to me like and to meet you
guys and to see how professional you
guys were
and alan king you know i'm a [__]
dirty comic
you're a real deal [__] actor
alessandro
so well i'll tell you what like you know
it may have like come as a surprise to
you that you had to like say your
[__] lines or whatever and not make
this [__] up but
it sure sounded improvised to me uh
in the best possible way which is really
you know
what the whole point of it is is to kind
of find that that
uh spontaneity and um
you know you you just have like such a
kind of
effortless authenticity in it and it's
like a major major grounding force in
the movie you know well
thank you i think uh the best night we
had and i want to tell this story is the
night that
we had one more scene to shoot it's got
to be four in the [__] morning we've
been there
all day and it's you and all of a sudden
they rap me
do you remember that night they rap me i
go back to the room
like [__] 12 hours my feet hurt i'm
gonna smoke a [__] biggest joint in
the world and call
uber i smoked the joint had to be two
feet [__] long
i ate an edible i i did a [__]
roots and all of a sudden i'm waiting
for the [__] uber on a corner of
brooklyn
at four in the morning i'm waiting not
to get mugged there's these dudes
walking towards me i'm like i'm gonna
get [__] mugged and also
i see the girl from this thing come up
to me she's like i really hate to tell
you this because they unwrapped you
you gotta put your suit on and go back
and i'm like you're not [__] serious
you're not [__] serious it's four in
the morning and i wasn't tired or
anything i was just you know
and i remember giggling while i put the
suit on and i
walk in and you're there my boy from
hamilton is there
and all of a sudden king goes i'm sorry
and i go you're sorry let me tell you
something
this is the most unprofessional [__]
thing that's ever been done for me
not even on your part on my part too
and you called me back at four in the
[__] morning this is the most
and we [__] died him the [__] arab
camera dude was a pisser the guy that i
used to call syria whatever the [__]
so what am i gonna see you buddy you're
around uh yeah let's do it
soon i um i'm here uh
definitely for the next uh little while
my kids
unbelievably have been cast
in this huge movie um
and which had nothing to do with us it
came through their school
and um next thing i know
they're filming in ohio
all summer long and uh
my wife and i have to like tag team
like chaperoning these kids all summered
out well they eclipsed both of our
careers
it's all over man it's all
all over but we'll be back but that
doesn't start to
don't start till june so so uh i'm here
before that we got it we got to get
together before then
okay and then we got the big premiere
september 24th
finally the movie yeah yeah let's
how they do it i don't know if we'll go
to like some festivals and stuff
or you know i don't know we'll see i'm
waiting to hear how they're gonna
how they're gonna roll it out but yeah
i'm just but
i gotta see we gotta see you way before
that okay yeah i'll come into the city
we'll do some lunch or something what's
that
yeah you got the phone no i'm saying
that's the light that way
that's a lifetime away we gotta
we we need to uh we need to catch up
long before that oh no no i'll see you
in a few weeks
let me let let's let this vaccination
get in me
i think i'll be yeah i just had my
second one uh two days ago myself yeah i
did my monday i did my one
one and um i went to the gym today yeah
i went to the gym yesterday too so i
don't know you know
i don't know if wait you got your first
you just got your first one no i got a
johnson johnson one shot
you got one and done cuban oh yeah i was
up with the cubans i couldn't you know
what they're not are there no side
effects on that one not
so far you know i feel like my head's a
little my head's kind of throbbing but
that's
yeah i had the beginnings of a headache
but i took two [__] uh
whatever tylenol yeah and i was tip top
magoo
alessandro thank you for taking care of
me on the set
thank you for being a big brother and
for taking me under your wing and for
making me feel
like a real actor instead of a [__]
jamok
i love you give your wife a kiss and
congratulate the boys for me buddy
love you too stay black you got it
i hope you enjoyed that [__] let
me tell you something about
alessandro he's won the screen actors
award
he's been nominated for a [__] couple
things
he's in the movie uh the wizard of lies
the [__] one with the uh he's got a
movie with the kid from
social uh the facebook movie
social he's got a great art of
discipline or something like that what's
the name of it
the art of self-defense that's a good
little [__] movie he did
that i caught a few weeks ago he's got a
couple great movies
face off watch face off alessandro is a
[__] real pro and i'm happy we got
him
it's a monday morning [__] podcast
thank you for watching the joint uh i
appreciate you [__]
you know me i'm everywhere on my dog
[__] instagram
twitter patreon follow me and if not
that's it and that's that now for a word
for my [__] sponsors
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank alessandro
again for coming on the show but most
importantly i want to thank you guys for
always having my back
on a monday morning don't forget if
you're looking for a ps5
they're hard to come by but cbd lion is
making your dreams come true
they're having a [__] raffle over
there cbd lion
you ready for this for every ticket for
every ten dollars you bought you spend
you get a ticket you spend fifty dollars
you get five tickets and that's more
chances for you to win
the ps5 over at cbdlion.com
it's enter you can enter for free also
you don't need to no purchase necessary
so that's the kind of deal they're
running over there right now for 420 but
when it comes to cbd i only trust a lion
i've been working with them for four
years on my own
and during this surgery they came
through for me with my own
i still put on pieces of the kinesiology
tape i still take the back ball you know
i still use the back walls in fact i'm
out of bath balls i gotta get some more
batboy
but anyway it don't make the [__]
point cbd lion works at night when i get
home
before i watch tv with the family i ice
my knee i put the tins on there
and i put some cbd lion lotion on that
thousand milligrams
i feel tip top [__] magoo
so go to cbd line right now read read up
on cbd and the benefits for you
whether it's cbd cbn cby
you gotta start by reading okay go to
cbd line right now
register to win your free ps5 enter the
enter to get into the contest to win the
p
s five right now but besides that if
you're looking for cbd
this is the way to go the liquor store
guy ain't gonna help you the guy at the
foot store ain't gonna help you
uncle joey's gonna help you just go to
cbdline.com right now and read
read on the great selection of cbd
products whether it's the back ball
kinesiology tape the chalk of the
tincture go to cbdlion.com right now
press in church and get 20 off delivered
to your house
the joint is also brought to you by on a
beautiful monday
moochu spring is here forget the [__]
birds and the bees
it's time to go in deep deep deep
get blue chew and combat all forms of ed
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis at a fraction
of the cost blue chew brings you the
first chewable dick pill
ah no more [__] [__] from the liquor
store
no more buying pills at the tire center
blue chew is an online prescription
service no visits to doctor's office
no awkward conversations and no waiting
online
for the pharmacy let me tell you
something maybe you're not suffering
from
erectile dysfunction like your uncle
joey when you get old
you can sling dick with three hands but
why not go with two guns be prepared
you want them to call you back
bluechew.com's got the answer
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
you talk to one of the licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you receive the prescription online
within days it's that easy
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package the mailman don't even
know dick no
nobody knows dick just blue chew blue
shoe tablets are made in the usa
and prepare this ship directly it's way
cheaper than the pharmacy so go to you
blue chew right now right now they got a
special deal for you you know i always
show up with something for you
[__] on a monday
i'm not gonna leave you out there you
know it's either a ps5
something try blue chew for free with
joy what are you talking about it's
monday why are you playing tricks on me
because like go to blue chew for free
right now
by using promo code joey at checkout all
you're gonna do is pay five dollars for
the
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
joey to receive
your first month free and as always i
want to thank bluechu
for sponsoring the joint i want to thank
buchu
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
alessandro but
most importantly i want to thank you
[__] savages for always having my
back
on a monday morning and supporting the
[__] joint okay
i love you [__] stay black have a
great [__] day
and i'll see you wednesday ready to go
tip top magoo to stab a [__] in
the neck
don't be stabbing nobody right now only
in l.a they're not pressing charges so
it's not bad
but everywhere else you got to be a
christian i love you [__] stay
black
have a great week and i'll see you guys
wednesday ready to rock
[Music]
so
you